monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues avec mes
collègues j'ai souhaité attirer votre
attention sur un sujet qui nous
préoccupe gravement
c'est notre relation avec les pays du
Maghreb et en particulier avec le Maroc
cette relation avec un pays historique
et dégradé nous y étions il y a peu avec
le président Combon et une délégation du
groupe d'amitié et nous avons pu mesurer
l'état de dégradation de la relation
entre la France et le Maroc nous sommes
pas reçus par le Mans dans les
ministères on est reçu dans les parties
ou à domicile même si ces chaleureux et
donc on voit bien que depuis deux ans
le Maroc qui est un pays ami
historiquement depuis longtemps où nous
avons beaucoup d'intérêts et qui
constitue nos yeux et nos oreilles dans
cette région et bien
est en difficulté dans sa relation avec
la France alors cette relation elle
n'est pas exclusive de ce que nous
pouvons faire de façon équilibrée avec
l'Algérie ça c'est fait pendant
plusieurs années de nombreuses années
nous avons consenti de gros efforts en
direction de l'Algérie président de la
République s'y est rendu peu de temps
après madame la Première ministre vous y
êtes allé avec une grande délégation
force est de constater que c'est
renoncement finalement que nous avons
consenti ont été peu couronnés de succès
si j'en crois les dernières mesures du
gouvernement algérien qui a cru de voir
réintroduire un couplet assez peu amical
en direction de la France dans l'hymne
national
et bien
président de la République a reçu hier
madame Meloni
ce qui existe entre l'Italie ce qui
existe avec le Maroc et l'Algérie c'est
l'Union européenne c'est l'Union
Méditerranéenne pardon et l'Union pour
la Méditerranée est en rade il y a pas
d'autres mots depuis plusieurs années
maintenant depuis longtemps maintenant
et donc il est indispensable que pour
affirmer la place de la France en
Méditerranée pour que nous puissions
engager un dialogue utile sur les
problèmes migratoires et pesés au sein
de l'Union européenne il est
indispensable que nous puissions
relancer cette Union pour la
Méditerranée et que nous puissions
travailler à nouveau dans des conditions
de confiance avec le Maroc parce que les
Marocains sont nos amis au Maghreb donc
madame la Première ministre
quelles initiatives pardon quelle
initiative comptez-vous prendre pour
relancer l'Union pour la Méditerranée et
les relations avec le Maroc
merci
pour vos réponses
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs des sénateurs monsieur le
président Hervé Marseille
la France a une relation très riche une
histoire partagée et des liens humains
particulièrement étroits avec le Maroc
comme avec l'Algérie
une histoire de cette intensité n'est
jamais dépassionnée et je veux le redire
nous avons un objectif clair
développé et approfondir nos liens dans
le respect mutuel avec chacun des deux
pays avec l'Algérie nous continuons à
travailler dans l'esprit de la
déclaration d'Alger pour un partenariat
renouvelé entre la France et l'Algérie
vous l'avez dit je me suis moi-même
rendu à Alger en octobre 2022 quelques
semaines après la visite du président de
la République pour qu'au présider le
Comité intergouvernemental de haut
niveau les deux présidents de la
République échangent de façon très
régulière nous souhaitons aller de
l'avant il y a bien sûr des obstacles
mais surtout il y a une volonté une
volonté commune partagée par le
président Macron et le président teboun
de regarder vers l'avenir et de
construire au bénéfice de nos deux
peuples nous restons bien évidemment
vigilants notamment dans le domaine
migratoire nous avons sur ce sujet
un dialogue exigeant en particulier sur
la réadmission des ressortissants
algériens en situation irrégulière
avec le Maroc nos liens sont très forts
qu'ils soient humain économique ou
culturelle la relation franco-marocaine
ce sont par exemple plus de 46 000
étudiants marocains en France
46000 élèves dans les établissements
français au Maroc et plus de 1000
filiales d'entreprises françaises la
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères Catherine Colonna s'est rendu
au Maroc en décembre dernier pour une
visite très positive le souhait de la
France est de poursuivre
l'approfondissement de ce partenariat
d'exception au service des intérêts que
partage nos deux pays et à la hauteur de
la relation que nous voulons avec le
Maroc et vous avez raison monsieur le
Président Marseille l'avenir de nos
relations avec l'Algérie et le Maroc
comme avec la Tunisie s'inscrit plus
largement dans notre politique pour la
Méditerranée la France est à l'origine
de l'Union pour la Méditerranée elle
continuera à prendre à prendre des
initiatives fortes
pour renforcer les liens entre les deux
rives et pour apporter ensemble des
réponses concrètes à nos défis communs
notamment en matière d'environnement je
vous remercie
la parole est à notre collègue Katia
pour ce poli pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste